some Republicans and Democrats say the
president's strong words are not helping
the situation mr. Trump echoed the tone
of another presidential statement made
as the u.s. attacked Japan with nuclear
weapons 72 years ago this week major
Garrett is near the trump National Golf
Club in New Jersey major good morning
good morning President Trump wrote from
his working vacation to sound an alarm
of sorts using vivid imagery and
rhetoric meant is to capture the
attention of nations throughout Asia
especially China but beyond that Cold
War imagery of fire and fury the Trump
administration has not articulated a
policy to stop North Korea or defuse
this crisis when asked if President
Trump was moving toward war counselor
Kellyanne Conway couldn't or wouldn't
say I think the president's comments
were very strong and obvious the
president prides himself on not drawing
red lines or telegraphing military
intentions even so mr. Trump's phrases
sounded very much like a speech Harry
Truman gave after the first u.s. atomic
bomb strike on Hiroshima if they do not
now accept our terms they may expect a
rain of ruin from the air the like of
which has never been seen on this earth
over the weekend the United Nations
Security Council voted unanimously to
impose new sanctions on North Korea in
response to continued ballistic missile
tests about the same time National
Security Adviser HR McMaster said
military action is a real option are we
preparing plans for a preventive war
right if they have nuclear weapons get
throughout the United States it's
intolerable from the president's
perspective America's appetite for
conflict appears limited only 29 percent
favor military action in a CBS News poll
and 61 percent are uneasy about the
president's ability to solve the crisis
some Democrats took pause senator Ben
Cardin of Maryland said Trump's comments
once again show that he lacks the
temperament and Senator Dianne Feinstein
said Trump was bombastic and is not
helping the situation but Republican
Congressman Peter King said Trump's
comments send a very strong deterrence
signal to North Korea to me there's more
of a chance of
war if the u.s. does not stand strong on
Phoenix radio Republican Senator John
McCain was critical of mr. Trump the
great leaders that I've seen they don't
threaten unless they are ready to act
yeah and I'm not sure that President
Trump is ready to act the president
confronts this situation without a full
team of his own Asia experts and
advisers he has not nominated an
ambassador to South Korea and other top
State Department Asia positions remain
vacant overall about 60% of assistant
secretary in undersecretary positions at
the State Department have either been
confirmed nominated or potential
nomination nominees rather are being
screened for those positions Charlie
thanks major